there is a truly fascinating and
stunning a new PPP poll exposing the
Donald Trump supporters live to a pretty
significant degree in a total and
complete fantasy world the fantasy world
that Donald Trump voters are living in
today sort of reminds me of the fantasy
world that Republican supporters of the
Iraq war were living in during 2004
there's a very famous P IPA poll that
was done it was done around 2004 might
have been late 2003 or 2004 which I
encourage you to check out and in it it
showed that Republicans were highly
likely to believe three false notions
this is 2004 okay number one many
Republicans in oh four thought we found
weapons of mass destruction in Iraq of
course that wasn't true in 2004 many
Republicans believe that there was a
connection between 9/11 and and bin
Laden to Iraq and Saddam Hussein of
course there was no connection and
number three many Republicans in 2004
believed that world opinion of the US
going into Iraq was positive all were
wrong all were a total alternate reality
and we have a similar situation today
with Trump supporters let's take a look
at what this PPP poll has found based on
what Trump supporters believe today for
example 39% of Trump supporters think
that the stock market has decreased
under President Obama it's actually up
over 100 percent it's more than doubled
two-thirds of Trump supporters think
unemployment is up under President Obama
in fact it's down from 7.8 percent to
4.6 percent 40 percent of Trump voters
believe that Donald Trump won the
popular vote that's similar to it to
last week's poll there's one other poll
that says it's actually 52% of Trump
voters think Trump won the popular vote
of course he lost the popular vote by
nearly 3 million votes to Hillary
Clinton 60% of Trump supporter
supporters believe that millions of
people voted illegally for Hillary
Clinton that has not been demonstrated
by any evidence whatsoever 73 percent of
Trump voters believe that George Soros
paid Trump protesters a widely debunked
conspiracy theory from the fake news
world and 29 percent of Trump voters
basically 3 and 10 Trump voters think
the California vote shouldn't be
included in the popular vote just
arbitrarily we just shouldn't include
the California popular vote in the world
a countrywide gnash nationwide national
popular vote totals Trump voters live in
a fantasy world and this is not a matter
of opinion it is a matter of fact this
is why I have said that by and large it
doesn't matter whether Trump makes
America great again the trumpets are
going to think he did because the facts
don't matter to them and we know that
the political rewards the Trump for just
lying have been huge this is what you
get pat when you have a candidate whose
primary justification for his claims and
beliefs are it's true because I say it's
true yeah and if you're a low
information voters or all you take in is
Rush Limbaugh on Fox News I could see
how you could fall for this sort of
thing but some of these things are just
ludicrous I mean there's no reasonable
way to say that the country is a worse
position than when Obama took office and
why would you think that
California's vote shouldn't even count
yeah no I mean you know just lots of
liberals there and it distorts stuff
well so do all those low population red
states in the middle of the country I
mean almost nobody lives there they
shouldn't even count their electoral
votes right who would accept that it
doesn't make any sense and this relates
to why people who stand to lose from
Trump being president
insist on voting for him because their
lives for the last 20 or 30 years in
many cases have been materially worsened
by Republican policy but they have been
brought up in a culture and in a way
where they believe the lies told by
Trump they believe that Republican ideas
help to improve their lives and they do
not this is a real real difficult
situation that we are heading into